how air pollution threatens natural pest
control methods in sustainable
farming few individuals are aware of the
dangers that air pollution poses to both
people and the
environment humans who breathe polluted
air are more likely to get cancer heart
disease and even birth
defects Additionally the disruption of
the natural ecosystem caused by air
pollution from different human
activities such as industrial
manufacturing car emissions and power
plants reduces biodiversity by altering
the migratory patterns of plants and
animals and affects wildlife
habitats this could jeopardize Farmers
usage of non-toxic non-GMO natural Pest
management techniques genetically
modified
organisms here is how air pollution
endangers organic pest management
techniques used in sustainable
agriculture air pollution has been
recognized as an increasingly major
Hazard to the environment in recent
years
for instance a research reported in the
journal science indicated that both
indoor and outdoor air pollution
contribute to up to 8 million premature
deaths
annually both natural and man-made
sources such as car emissions and
Industrial Waste gases directly release
pollutants into the air
outside air pollution's effects on
organic
farming natural Pest Management
strategies in sustainable agriculture
are under danger due to the growing
issue of air
pollution the health of plants is
impacted by higher levels of pollutants
including ozone particulate matter and
nitrogen dioxide because they cause
premature fruit ripening which can
reduce yields in quality due to
decreased pest defenses when crops are
stressed by air pollution they are also
more prone to bug
infestation this may lead to lower crop
yields and a higher need for
insecticides the danger of organic pest
control
techniques one of the most
environmentally friendly ways to care
for crops is through natural pest
control
methods however a recent study indicates
that the pollution from factories farms
and Autos may be endangering these
organic Pest Management
strategies researchers discovered that
ladybugs struggle to locate their meal
when there is a lot of air pollution
around additionally it prevents them
from having
Offspring a healthy environment depends
on ladybugs which also help keep insect
populations in check and potentially
save Farmers a lot of money on
pesticides future of sustainable
agriculture sustainable farming is
gaining popularity as a means of feeding
a rising population well while
preserving the
environment the use of natural Pest
management techniques such as crop
rotation or chemical-free fertilizers as
opposed to pesticides is one of the main
benefits of sustainable
farming Recent research has revealed
that air pollution may be endangering
these organic pest management
techniques please subscribe to enjoy
more
videos thank you
[Music]